[Music]
5 at 11 live local now put ccsd board
members the general public and the idea
of a vaccine mandate together and you're
going to have a lot of drama thank you
for joining us at 11 i'm brian loftis
and i'm denise valdez the special board
meeting to talk about a vaccine mandate
for school employees spiraled out of
control sasha loftis has been there
throughout the night she joins us now
live with the latest
denise and brian that meeting is still
going it started at five o'clock tonight
public comment lasted around five hours
and at last check ccsd trustees the
superintendent and medical experts were
discussing the idea of a vaccine mandate
now earlier tonight things did spiral
out of control as you mentioned people
were protesting shouting screaming
making sure their voices were heard
impassioned protests and emotional
outbursts over the idea of covid vaccine
mandates i'm here to assign ccsd a big
fat f i don't want to have a board
deciding what i can do with my body we
have to grow up and stop throwing
tantrums like five year olds over a
vaccine superintendent dr jesus jarrah
spoke out during wednesday's special
meeting to share his perspective and
cite a surge in coronavirus infections
across our community the best medically
available mitigation strategy
we currently have is the vaccine he also
made it clear that a yes vote from the
board to mandate staff immunization
would simply be the first step to create
a well thought out plan the authority
that i am requesting is to allow me as
the superintendent to develop a plan and
processes
necessary
to implement the full vaccination of our
staff regardless many who attended this
meeting downtown say any mandate would
go against their medical choice i think
you need to start listing the people in
the audience and the people that are on
social media that are speaking out and
they urged district leaders to decide
against it i think it would be a real
disaster for our community
now as of today there have been just
over 1600 positive coveted 19 cases
across the school district 980 of those
are students now dr jarrah made it clear
today earlier in the evening that this
mandate would only apply to staff would
not involve students now again this
discussion is still happening this
meeting is still going on make sure to
stay with 8 news now throughout the
night and starting at 4 a.m tomorrow for
the latest on this decision reporting
live sasha loftis 8 news now